Viserys Targaryen: The days of the Andals
were numbered.
One by one, their so-called kings were bending
the knee or facing the wrath of Aegon Targaryen.
Aegon of Old Valyria, Aegon, who was "blood
of the dragon."
Theon Greyjoy: When Aegon came demanding fealty,
King Harren the Black ruled as far east as
the Trident.
Yara: Other kings, like the Starks, could
kneel, but Harren was ironborn, and the ironborn
must be beaten.
In Harrenhal, he had the mightiest castle
in Westeros, and the army to defend it.
Theon: But Aegon did not intend a siege.
He mounted his dragon and roasted Harren and
all his sons in their tower, and the old way
with them.
Because of Harren's defiance, Aegon pushed
the Ironborn back to our islands and gave
the Riverlands to the Tullys.
But he did allow the ironborn to choose who
would lead them.
Brynden Tully: The old River Kings, Storm
Kings, and the Kings of the Rock spilled blood
here for thousands of years, squabbling like
children over a new toy.
Until the ironborn came and spanked them with
their axes.
Under Harren the Black, their kingdom stretched
all the way to the Gods Eye, where they built
the largest castle Westeros had ever seen.
Maesters teach that Harren was a fool, but
he had some sense.
If you're going to enslave and torture an
entire people, you best have thick walls to
hide behind.
But the very day the last stone was laid in
Harrenhal, Aegon Targaryen landed in Westeros.
Euron Greyjoy: Harwyn Hoare, born to a king
who had a fleet he didn't sail, and swords
he didn't blood.
As an unruly and worthless youngest son, Harwyn
was sent away to the east to vanish, and so
he did.
But when his father died, Harwyn returned
to the Iron Islands for the kingsmoot.
An elder brother objected so an elder brother
fell off a horse, and at the kingsmoot, no
man objected.
Harwyn launched his father's ships for Westeros
and took ten times the Iron Islands from its
weak lords who never expected to face an ironborn
king as skilled on land as at sea.
For Harwyn had reaved with eastern pirates
and served with eastern sellswords and learned
more of war than the ironborn could imagine.
After Aegon and his dragons burned our last
king, Harren the Black, and broke our armies,
the defeated ironborn chose my ancestor, Vickon
Greyjoy, as Lord of the Iron Islands, not
king.
Robert Baratheon: House Baratheon was born
in the Wars of Conquest when Aegon the Dragon
invaded Westeros.
Aegon sent his commander, Orys Baratheon,
to take Storm's End.
Argilac the Arrogant, the last of the Storm
Kings, foolishly left the safety of his stronghold
and met the Baratheon warlord in open battle.
Argilac was soundly defeated, and Orys took
his lands, his holdings, and his daughter.
Orys was said to be a half-brother to Aegon
Targaryen.
If this were true, a little blood of the dragon
mingled with that of the stag in those days.
The seat of House Baratheon is Storm's End,
a legendary keep raised in the Age of Heroes.
It overlooks Shipbreaker Bay, where legend
has it that Durran, the first Storm King,
raised the keep with the aid of Bran the Builder
of House Stark, forging a centuries-long connection
with the Stormlands and the North.
After Aegon's conquest of the Seven Kingdoms,
the Baratheons remained loyal enough to the
crown while Targaryen kings came and went.
But loyalty has its limits.
Viserys Targaryen: After defeating the ironmen
at Harrenhal and slaying the last of the Storm
Kings, Aegon and his sisters, Rhaenys and
Visenya, set their sights on other prizes.
The gold mines of the Rock and the fertile
lands of the Reach.
King Loren Lannister of the Rock and King
Mern Gardener of the Reach foolishly thought
their combined armies could beat back the
Targaryen host.
They rode forth together, their proud banners
flapping in the wind, and faced off against
Aegon in a vast golden field of wheat.
The two kings commanded a massive force of
nearly sixty thousand and it appeared the
day was theirs.
Until Aegon unleashed all three of his dragons,
for the first and only time.
Each beast was named after the Valyrian gods
of Aegon's forefathers.
Visenya rode Vhagar, whose fiery breath could
melt armor.
Rhaenys rode Meraxes, whose jaws were big
enough to swallow a horse whole.
The greatest of all was Balerion the Black
Dread, with fire dark as night and wings so
huge, whole towns were covered in shadow when
he flew overhead.
This magnificent creature was ridden by Aegon
himself.
Four thousand men were bathed in glorious
dragon flame that day, on what came to be
known as the Field of Fire.
King Mern was among the dead, and House Gardener
died with him.
His stewards, the Tyrells, surrendered his
ancestral stronghold of Highgarden to Aegon
and were appointed Lords Paramount of the
Reach and Wardens of the South.
When Loren Lannister witnessed Mern's fate,
he wisely bent the knee.
Aegon spared Loren's life, and the Lannisters
were made Lords Paramount of the Westerlands
and Wardens of the West.
Margaery Tyrell: Unlike the Lannisters, Starks,
and Arryns, we were never kings in our own
right.
House Gardener ruled the Reach since the Dawn
Age, and we were their stewards.
While they warred to enrich their already
rich domain, we managed their castle of Highgarden.
But then Aegon Targaryen landed with his dragons.
Nobody knows why the Gardener King took the
field up against him.
Anyone could see that a man who grows flowers
should beware a man who grows fire-breathing
monsters.
But maybe it wasn't wholly his idea.
Maybe someone whispered in his ear about all
the face he would lose with the other six
kings if he stayed home.
The rest is history.
The last Gardener King lost his face, along
with his body, and his steward Harlen Tyrell
promptly yielded Highgarden to Aegon.
My grandmother swears that Harlen was like
most of our men and grew up banging steel
too loudly for thought to penetrate, but luckily
his wife had better sense.
Whatever the case, in return for Harlen's
show of sense, Aegon proclaimed House Tyrell
the lords of the Reach and Wardens of the
South, passing over all the other houses with
better claims.
Some Great Houses call us upstarts, but the
truth is that while the Starks and Lannisters
fell to the Targaryens in defeat, House Tyrell
rose.
For thousands of years, our family served
as loyal stewards to the Kings of the Reach.
Until the last of their line unwisely burned
to death, resisting the Targaryen invaders.
To save the Reach from a similar fate, we
yielded the castle of Highgarden to Aegon
and his sisters.
In gratitude, the Targaryens gave House Tyrell
dominion over the Reach, and we became lords
of the castle in which, for generations, we
had served.
Qyburn: When Aegon the Conqueror was earning
his name, House Hightower traded its loyalty
to the Gardeners for his confirmation of their
rights, welcoming him with open arms and open
gates.
Pycelle: House Hightower bent the knee to
Aegon to spare the city from his dragons.
I would think such insinuations and insults
beneath even you, Qyburn.
Then again, mockery of one's betters is the
trade of fools.
Qyburn: I wouldn't know.
Robb Stark: The Starks reigned as kings for
thousands of years, even withstanding the
invasion of the Andals.
As the southern kingdoms fell, and the Children
of the Forest were driven away, the North
stood strong, maintaining its religious customs
and its way of life.
Eventually, the reign of the Kings of Winter
came to an end with the coming of Aegon the
Conqueror.
After Aegon and his dragons destroyed the
combined armies of the Reach and the Rock
at the Field of Fire, King Torrhen Stark bent
the knee and swore fealty to the Targaryen
dynasty in order to spare the destruction
of Winterfell and his people.
He was forever after known as "the King Who
Knelt."
As a reward for his submission, Aegon named
Torrhen Lord of Winterfell and Warden of the
North.
Catelyn Stark: Aegon the Conqueror arrived
in Westeros.
House Arryn bent the knee to Aegon and his
dragons and were allowed to maintain their
control of the region as Lords Paramount of
the Vale and Wardens of the East.
Varys: King's Landing is both a city and a
curse.
Aegon the Conqueror was the first king to
land there.
His first conquest, a tiny village at the
mouth of the Blackwater River, where he raised
a wooden fort.
When it became clear that Aegon would earn
his title, people flocked to the fort and
renamed it "King's Landing" in his honor.
The ploy succeeded, and Aegon chose King's
Landing for his capital over older and more
beautiful cities like Oldtown and anywhere
else.
The currying of royal favor thus became the
foundation of the city, and blood its bricks.
Oberyn Martell: Eventually, after centuries
of courtship, House Martell got into bed with
the Targaryens.
We took King Daeron II and his sister for
our own before they could take each other,
and six kingdoms became seven.
Even now, I do not blame my ancestors.
One look at those long silver locks.
It is not every day a man gets to ride a dragon.
Viserys Targaryen: Aegon's conquest was assured.
In a short time, the so-called Seven Kingdoms
were melted down in the heat of the dragons'
flame and transformed into a single realm.
Aegon would forever be known as Aegon the
Conqueror.